nous nous rendons village d'alexandre
onfray à proximité immédiate de la ligne
de contact et où la hausse des tensions
depuis le début de l'année se traduit de
façon très complet sans nom comme les
bombardements sont devenus deux fois
plus fréquents alors qu'auparavant seuls
des armes légères étaient utilisés on
tire maintenant avec des canons d'un
calibre de 30 mm dspg dbm paix avec
toutes les munitions comme les unités
ukrainiennes sont officiellement entrés
dans le village nous nous sommes séparés
d'elle que par l'eau c'est-à-dire 250
mètres environ où un homme a été tué
récemment il ya eu trois incidents de ce
type au cours des deux derniers mois des
snipers isolés travail et surtout la
nuit avec un équipement sophistiqué
il ya eu deux blessés graves et un mort
les bombardements continuent tous les
jours
la nuit c'est évident on entend des tirs
de snipers et d'armes légères cela se
poursuit également pendant la journée
machenaud les médecins m'ont chambré
hier encore il y ait eu un terrible
bombardement en plein centre du village
avec des bmp 2 g data center nous avons
pu recueillir le témoignage d'alexandre
un habitant du village qui également
électricien il s'occupe de réparer les
lignes électriques
et c'est définitivement un métier à haut
risque dans le contexte actuel dès que
la guerre a commencé on a pris les
choses en main on a formé une brigade
j'ai pris ma mobylette et je suis allé
le long d'une plantation forestière
une fois que nous avons tous fait
quelqu'un nous a dénoncé une chasse à
l'oeuf et rebelote
nous avons tout fait et une heure ou une
heure et demie plus tard ils ont
commencé à bombarder ce territoire et
moi j'ai entendu dire que vous aviez est
également touché oui plusieurs fois
c'était un miracle ou bien je suis né
coiffé sinon j'aurais pu crever la
première fois c'était en 2014 au 7 rue
kirov j'ai grimpé sur un poteau je me
suis attaché avec une ceinture et je
m'occupais d'un isolant électrique celui
tout en haut
l'obus à voler au dessus de ma tête et
s'est désintégré en morceaux j'ai
compris qu'il y avait eu un tir et qu'il
s'était désintégré
les gars m'ont crié descendu à faire
tuer nous nous trouvons simplement à
quelques centaines de la ligne de front
qui se situe de ce côté là et voilà le
genre de surprise que les habitants de
ce village peuvent retrouver dans leur
jardin
ceci provient d'un char ça ça vient d'un
canon automoteur de 122 mm l'obus a été
désactivé ceci est un ouragan un lance
roquettes multiples cet ouragan a tué
deux personnes un jeune homme de 18 ans
et une femme de 64 ans rue kirov
ce sont des missiles à fragmentation ce
sont les missiles antichars avec
lesquels ils nous bombardent
ces derniers ont complètement détruit le
deuxième étage d'un bâtiment au 9 de la
rue check your skin cf
c'est un missile guidé antichars nous
avons un nombre incalculable de
munitions de canon sans recul antichars
rpg 7
nous les appelons carottes je voulais
déjà dit nous en avons compté 500 chacun
dans ce village est touché de près ou de
loin par cette guerre alors bien sûr la
peur existe la peur est présente mais il
faut bien continuer à vivre pour
l'instant il commence de nouveau à
bombarder nuitées jour et le matin
le pire c'est quand les enfants sont à
l'école près de laquelle se trouve
prétendument un kolkhoze en réalité le
poste de contrôle 0 et ils commencent à
tirer dans la journée quand les enfants
sont à l'école et c'est la chose la plus
terrible maintenant on est chez soi et
on a ces enfants là bas on ne sait
jamais s'il y aura assez de temps pour
revenir on est toujours au téléphone
les parents sont ici à bout de nerfs or
a dit l'elysée
malgré la menace constante des grenades
et des snipers la vie continue les
enfants vont à l'école
les personnes âgées s'occupe du jardin
du potager les gens vaquent à leurs
occupations
la vie continue car au final il n'y a
pas d'autre choix